Oh, dogs! A best friend that always has your
back - in fact, studies have shown that men
are 3 times more likely to get a girls phone
number if they have a dog by their side!
And do you ever feel like your dog just “gets”
you? It turns out that humans and dogs both
respond to emotional sounds. When your dog
hears you crying or laughing, the response
in their brain is similar to that of a human's.
In fact, they interpret your crying as another
dog whining.
Which may make you want to cuddle your buddy
- but did you know that dogs often curl up
into a ball when sleeping to conserve body
heat and protect their most vulnerable organs
in the abdomen from predators? Comfy! If you’re
not always around to cuddle, leaving them
some clothes that smell like you will actually
help them with separation anxiety.
And while you may think you have the smartest
dog, animal psychologists believe most dogs
are about as smart as a 2 year old human.
Dogs can understand more than 150 words, count
up to 5, and notice simple errors such as
1+1=3. Dogs are also capable of solving spatial
problems; they learn the location of hidden
treats, find the fastest route to the park
and operate mechanisms such as latches and
simple machines.
And by the way, dogs aren’t completely colourblind
as many people think! But unlike the three
specialized receptors in our eyes to distinguish
colours, dogs only have two. Because of this,
they see black, white, blue and yellow. Meanwhile,
their brains don’t interpret red and green,
but instead see grey.
Of the 75 million domesticated dogs in America,
labradors are the most popular, but the most
intelligent dog breeds are Border Collies,
Poodles, and German Shepherds. However, these
are measures of intelligence that compare
to our own; dogs are amazingly smart in other
ways. You’ve probably heard of drug sniffing
dogs, but did you know that dogs can sense
seizures, detect low blood sugar and can sniff
out cancer? In one study, dogs were able to
identify 30 of 33 cases of prostate cancer
by smelling participant’s urine. It is believed
that dog’s highly sophisticated sense of
smell can detect variation and the presence
of volatile organic compounds.
Their sense of smell is 10,000 to 10,000,000
times more sensitive than humans depending
on the breed. A secreted fluid from their
nose helps them smell by capturing scent chemicals
in a thin layer of wet mucous on their nose.
In fact, for a dog, breathing is different
than smelling. A small fold of tissue called
the alar fold separates the flow of air depending
on whether they are sniffing or breathing.
Which also allows them to pick up pheromones
in the air to help locate and determine the
readiness of possible mates. Tinder for dogs!
On top of it all, humans really do love dogs!
A recent study found that dogs activate the
same hormonal response that triggers us to
love and care for our own babies. Accompany
that with studies showing decreased stress
and anxiety, and it’s clear why they have
become such an important part of our lives.
They truly are Woman and Man’s best friend!
Unless you’re a cat lover...in which case
you should watch our scientific debate on
Cats vs Dogs, where we try and figure out
which precious pet is truly the best! Head
on over to that video to help us decide which
side wins!
And subscribe for more weekly science videos
:)